in our code we're going to initialize
the adapter within the placeholder
fragment oncreateview method because
that's where we want the ListView to be
populated with data we're using an array
adapter we can initialize it with four
parameters a context the ID of a list
item layout the ID of a textview within
that list item layout as well as the
list of data we'll go through each of
these parameters one by one now first
for context it contains global
information about the app environment it
allows us to access system services and
resources as well as the application
specific resources that we've defined we
use the fragments containing activity as
a context so we're going to call get
activity for our parameter here since
the adapter needs to know the layout for
each list item it needs some reference
to the XML layouts that we've defined
the our Java class is a generated file
that creates human readable identifiers
for our resources for the list item
layout we refer to encode as our layout
list item forecast this was the name of
the XML file that we created earlier
next the array adapter needs to know how
to take the weather forecast string and
set that to be displayed in a textview
so we pass in the ID of the textview
that we defined earlier in the list item
layout even though these two resource
IDs look similar one starts with our dot
layout while the other starts with our
de ID our layout refers to a layout file
while an ID refer to a specific XML
element with the matching ID attribute
and lastly we pass in week forecast
which is the ArrayList of forecast data
that we define earlier now go ahead and
initialize your adapter check this box
when you're done